ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States accompanied by the
vice president of the United States
thank you very much everybody
yes thank you you definitely have plenty
of distancing I've never seen distancing
like that that's really that's really
very impressive and welcome to the Rose
Garden as we take powerful action to
lower health care costs for America's
seniors today I'm proud to announce that
we have reached a breakthrough agreement
to dramatically slash the out-of-pocket
costs of insulin you know what's
happened to insulin over the years right
through the roof
insulin so many people so necessary for
hundreds and thousands of seniors
enrolled in Medicare that's a big deal
participating plans will cap cost at
just $35 a month per type of insulin and
some plans may offer it free so for
everybody that was getting ripped off
and paying tremendous prices senior
citizens and seem I want to thank you
because you brought this to my attention
a long time ago and you worked very hard
and this day and the press won't even
cover it but they'll cover things that
are unimportant but this is a big day
for seniors is a tremendous saving and
it allows people that you know if you
don't take insulin I just wrote this
down go blind stroke amputation
kidney failure and other things so we're
getting it at $35 per month and it would
be anywhere from 50 to 150 to over 200
dollars a month so it's a massive cut
sixty seventy percent nobody's seen
anything like this for a long time
sleepy joke into this that I can tell
you in fact it was his problem with
Obamacare that cause part of your
problem this will save impact in
Americans an average of minimum four
hundred and forty six dollars just on
insulin costs a year we're pleased to be
joined by Vice President Mike Pence and
Surgeon General Jerome Adams I also want
to thank Seema again thank you very much
for the job you've done helping achieve
the incredible victory for Medicare
patients nationwide in the past
Obamacare prevented insurance providers
from competing to offer lower costs for
seniors there was no competition there
was no anything and they ran away with
what took place and the seniors were
horribly hurt many people couldn't take
insulin they couldn't even think about
it as a result Medicare beneficiaries
with prescription drug coverage paid an
average of six hundred and seventy-five
dollars for a year's supply of insulin
and sometimes as high as $1,500 harmful
laws also meant that seniors often paid
a different amount almost every single
month they had no idea what they were
paying they were billed every month they
were billed a different amount that it
was a massive amount one in every three
seniors on Medicare has diabetes and
over 3.3 million beneficiaries used at
least one type of insulin over the past
ten years these seniors have seen their
out-of-pocket costs for this life-saving
treatment almost doubled I don't use
insulin should I be huh I never thought
about it but I know a lot of people are
very very badly affected right
unbelievable that's why my
administration acted decisively we
slashed Obamacare's crippling
requirements and opened up competition
like they've never seen before they've
never seen competition like this between
transparency and all of the other things
we're doing nobody's ever had a
competitive competitive situation
created like we've done it and the
prices you will see very soon they're
gonna come tumbling down
then we brought all the parties to the
table
insurers manufacturers and other key
players and reached an agreement to
deliver insulin at stable and
drastically lower out-of-pocket costs
for our seniors
I hope the seniors are gonna remember it
because Biden is the one that put us
into the jam because they didn't know
what they were doing they were
incompetent soon nearly half of all
eligible Part D and Medicare Advantage
prescription drug plans will offer this
low-cost option and when you say
low-cost you're really talking local
it's giving seniors the freedom and
choice to pick the plan that's right for
them nothing will ever stop me from
fulfilling my solemn duty to America's
seniors I'll use every power at my
disposal to lower drug prices and my
administration will always protect
Medicare and Social Security and by the
way pre-existing conditions and we got
rid of the individual mandate which is a
disaster the worst part of Obamacare was
the individual mandate when we got rid
of the individual mandate essentially we
got rid of Obamacare if you want to know
the truth you can say that in the truest
form but we get rid of a horrible
horrible condition called the individual
mandate but will always protect you on
pre-existing conditions much more so
than the Democrats here with us today is
Bruce Broussard president and ce CEO of
a big powerful health care company
Humana and I'd like that Bruce come up
and say a few words please Bruce thank
you that's a big company you are how
young he is - that's very young to be
running such a big company thank you
very much mr. president thank you Bruce
well we are I speak on behalf of our
fifty thousand teammates at work at
Humana that we are thankful of being
here and on
the demo that you are describing just
recently is an example of the strength
of public-private partnerships and
dealing with large issues such as the
affordability of prescription drugs and
insulin is by far the one that has used
the most another great example of that
is the response to the kovat and the
crisis and I think about one of our
customers Gwen
that just recently we served I did was
blind did not have access to food
no one could support her because no one
was in the vicinity to help her and in
addition didn't have access to her
prescriptions and through a strong
private public partnership we were able
to offer her food and prescriptions
delivered to her home so I want to thank
the administration for continuing to
pick on large issues like this and
bringing in the private enterprise to
assist in that so thank you Seema and
all everybody everything you've done so
thank you what did you buev done to
really an amazing job and thank you
you're also in the right business right
well if we can help any senior we're
always in the right that's good that's
good you've really helped that we
appreciate it very much thank you Bruce
we're also joined by Tracy Brown the CEO
of American Diabetes Association and a
lot of bad things can happen without
insulin in terms of diabetes and other
things please Tracy thank you very much
hey trace Thank You mr. president
Thank You administrator Verma for making
this afternoon one that we can focus on
the 34 million Americans like myself
who's living with diabetes 7 million of
which need insulin to live 25 percent of
these individuals have told us that they
ration or skip doses of their medicine
because they simply cannot afford it and
so this effort CMI MMI demonstration
project that brings together the
government industry and public health
advocacy from the American
diabetes association is the right thing
to do and we're thrilled to take this
challenge head-on today together we are
helping millions of seniors access
insulin affordably this is a very big
deal the American Diabetes Association
is the nation's leading organization
that fights for people living with
diabetes and we are committed to
continue to partner to make sure every
American and especially our seniors have
access to the medicine that they need to
live so thank you mr. president and
thank you administrator Verma so Traci
are you surprised at how much we've
gotten the price down to what extent and
to the level that we brought it down to
this is a very exciting day for people
living with diabetes and so any step to
bring this lower is the good good news
we know that we need to do more but I'm
so confident that together we're going
to be able to help all people living
with diabetes thrive good thank you very
much appreciate it yes I'd like to also
invite up David Rick's chairman CEO of
Eli Lilly and Company they're very big
in a very great company please there's
another young guy pleasure to be here
really an honor to be a part of this
announcement to improve the lives of so
many patients who live with diabetes in
our Part D program for several years
Lilly's worked hard to improve insulin
affordability and this has been a
missing piece that's now been filled in
by the great collaboration from our plan
companies like Bruce's who are here
Seema Verma your administration vice
president pans president Trump thank you
for your leadership to make this happen
this is the kind of collaboration that
solves real problems for people with
with serious issues like diabetes today
if you take Lilly insulin you will not
pay more than $35 except for in the Part
D program and we're pleased to add this
missing part to that equation so that
starting next year
seniors will benefit from that same
savings level just a little bit more
than a dollar a day for insulin that
same spirit of collaboration is also
being applied to collaboration around
covin 19 and I think everyone's aware
that there's thousands of scientists
working in our industry along with NIH
and other experts to speed around the
clock new therapies for patients
suffering from Kovan 19 and to arrest
and extinguish this pandemic I've never
been more proud to be a part of that
effort as well in this same spirit of
collaboration is being applied in that
incredibly important crisis as well
together by working together I think we
proved today we can solve long-term
problems and I hope I can come back
someday and show that we've solved the
immediate problem of copán 19 working as
an industry along with government so
thanks for having me here we will thank
you very much thanks David appreciate it
really good job I also want to thank the
companies with us today for rising to
the occasion in our fight against the
invisible enemy Humana and other
insurers have agreed to waive co-pays
which is a very great thing to do it's a
big it's a big deal thank you very much
coinsurance deductibles coronavirus
treatments for most enrollees I mean
what they did is really is people that
aren't in the business or even in
business period they wouldn't realize
how big a thing that is but it's a very
big thing and we appreciate it very much
coronavirus treatment for most enrollees
has been we've been moving along and
we're doing well we're gonna be
reporting on it in just a second Santa
Fe is working at breakneck speed to
create a vaccine Eli Lilly is been
developing therapeutics for corona virus
and expanding a free drive through
testing operations and thank you all for
the work it's been great
we're battling the virus on every front
speeding relief to our work workers and
pursuing therapies and vaccines at
record speed we have many companies
right now I think we can save very far
down the line on vaccines and
therapeutics and cures frankly they
Cure's are gonna be in there very
shortly manufacturing vast quality
quantities and medical equipment
supplies all of the different things
that you need we've energized our
military our military is ready
logistically to go out and distribute
whatever it is we come up with and I
think we're gonna come up with a lot I
think we're gonna have Terra Punic
remedies and I think we're gonna have
vaccines very shortly I've been saying
it very shortly I think I'll be proven
correct if I'm not I'm sure the media
will let us know about it
we're safely reopening our country while
aggressively protecting the vulnerable
especially our seniors we're telling our
seniors to stay back a little bit stay
back
let this thing pass we're not only
keeping older Americans safe from the
virus we're also ensuring that they have
the best medical care on earth at a
price that they can afford that's what
happened with insulin nobody can believe
it when they hear the price for the
insulin it's been an amazing difference
inseam is going to be talking about that
that's not just like a 10% drop or a 5%
drop which by itself would be good
that's a big that's a big drop that's a
really big drop we approved a record
number of generics and reverse the trend
of soaring drug prices for the first
time in over 50 years first time we've
ever had prices go down
average basic Part D premiums dropped
13.5 percent the lowest level in seven
years and we're going down verse
abstention from that level it's going
down very very substantial unless you
have a new administration to which case
it'll go up very substantially that I
can guarantee you they've been doing it
to you for years average Medicare
Advantage premiums have plummeted 28% to
the lowest level in over a decade and
that's despite everything that's been
happening which would normally make
things go up and we'd more then let's
see 1,200 more Medicare Advantage plans
today
that we did think of that two years ago
so we have 1,200 more Medicare Advantage
plans than we did two years ago that's
something I signed an executive order to
crack down on fraud in Medicare
and to give beneficiary faster access to
the latest medical devices and therapies
and to take all of the fraud money and
finding a lot of it all of that money
that we're finding in fraud or reduce
prices we provided nearly 1 billion
dollars in grants to support home
delivered meals and in-home care for
elderly patients and disabled people
during the pandemic we expanded
telehealth which has really turned out
to be a very hot subject right people
that never thought about it people that
didn't like the idea right Tracy they're
loving telehealth it's speedy and it's a
lot less expensive
we expanded telehealth for Medicare
beneficiaries and the number of patients
using it has increased from roughly
11,000 a week to nearly 1.3 million so
we went from 11 thousand people to 1.3
million people a week but very big where
you'll be seeing it price transparency
some people think it's better it's
bigger than health care when you look at
it it's going to be bigger than health
care price transparency it was signed
approximately nine months ago it's going
through the process and it'll be here by
the 1st of the year so I hope you're
gonna remember me just in case the
unthinkable happens but nobody else
would have gotten it but this
administration price transparency it's a
a tremendous it's gonna cut your costs
tremendously and literally one of the
biggest people in the field said Trice
parents it's going to be a bigger thing
price transparency bigger than health
care in a true sense the cost of health
care is going to come down very very
substantially we're always working on
pre-existing conditions and saving your
pre-existing conditions and as long as
I'm president you'll always be protected
on pre-existing conditions and surprise
medical billing is something your people
as surprised never in a positive sense
and we've written that out and that's
going to be very quickly ended so you're
not gonna be surprised meaning badly
surprised very negatively
it's a big thing people go in they go
for an operation they end up literally
losing all of their money losing
everything over something that should
not happen surprise medical billing
we're using every tool at our disposal
to protect our nursing homes from
outbreaks you saw the disaster of how
badly some of the governor's handled
nursing homes it's a disgrace what
they've done what the governor's what
some of the governor's have done is a
disgrace
we provided States more resources to
step up inspections added shipments of
personal protective equipment to all
15,400 Medicaid and Medicare certified
nursing homes and issued a strict new
guideline that every nursing home
resident and staffer be tested
immediately and that all staff be tested
weekly so we're making it very very
tough every day of my administration
we're fighting for our seniors like
never before our seniors are very
special people all of our citizens are
special but our seniors would have to
take care of our seniors our senior
citizens have spent their entire lives
working hard supporting their
communities and families and paying into
the system we will not rest until they
get the kind of care and support that
they have earned and that they deserve
now I'd like to ask vice president Mike
Pence to come up and say a few words
followed by administrative Vemma and I
would just like to thank you again for
the great job you've done so we'll have
Mike speak and then you'll speak and
thank you very much go ahead Mike thank
you Thank You mr. president
and and and let me say what a what a
privilege it is to be here with business
leaders and activists who have been
standing with you standing with the
White House coronavirus task force from
the very beginning it truly has been a
public-private partnership that's
marshaled not just a whole-of-government
approach but a whole of America
and we see that evident today in this
historic step for America's seniors and
let me join the president expressing our
profound gratitude to the servant heart
that each one of you have brought and
all of your employees have brought the
importance of today's announcement
cannot be overstated mr. president as
you observed early on we recognized that
the coronavirus represented a particular
threat to seniors with underlying health
conditions and diabetes being among them
and today's step ensures that as we
continue to work to safely reopen our
country we're going to make sure that
our seniors have access to affordable
health care to insulin and treatment to
be able to meet that moment along with
us mr. president we gather today with
the news that more than 98 thousand of
our countrymen have succumbed to the
corona virus and their families are in
our prayers and in our hearts but
because of the cooperation and the
compassion of the American people who
have heeded your guidelines for America
who have listened and continued to
listen to state and local authorities we
know that there are tens of thousands of
American families that have been spared
that heartbreak and loss and we we
express our gratitude to the American
people if you're incredible cooperation
the social distancing the steps that you
have embraced the way you have been
willing to forfeit aspects of your
personal freedom to put the health of
others first but the good news is mr.
president that because of the steps the
American people have taken heeding your
leadership and the guidance of state and
local officials we're getting there and
we're starting to reopen America as we
speak in a safe and responsible way in
fact mr. president every state in the
nation has now taken at least some steps
to
reopen their economies 52 states and
territories have opened retail curbside
to go with reduced capacity 44 states
we're glad to note have opened up
elective medical procedures in hospitals
and clinics around the state 38 states
and territories have reopened personal
care under strict hygiene protocols 37
states have reopened restaurants 34
states have reopened non-essential
businesses and the list goes on and I
think most meaningful to you mr.
president is so far thirty states and
territories have reopened houses of
worship under guidance of reduced
capacity while allowing people to come
back together in fellowship and prayer
this has all been made possible because
of the whole of government a whole of
America approach mr. president that you
initiated when you launched the White
House corona virus task force back in
January and before I stepped down let me
at least share a few encouraging words
that we shared with America's governors
today about the progress that we all
have been making because to continue to
safely reopen we believe it's absolutely
essential that we increase visibility by
expanding testing across the country so
that we can ensure that that we can
identify outbreaks where they occur it's
interesting as you watch the daily
numbers new cases are declining around
the country and even more dramatically
when you realize that a significant
portion of new cases every day are
actually in outbreaks in specific
businesses or as we discussed today in
nursing homes or in meatpacking plants
but I'm proud to report mr. president
because of the partnership that you
forged with commercial laboratories
around the country 14 point 1 million
tests have been performed and I heard
again today from governors across
America
how they have been in many cases
exceeding the demand in the testing that
they've made available in fact a
governor Phil Murphy of
of New Jersey and for me that he had
promised the people in New Jersey that
he would be doing 20,000 tests a day but
in partnership with the federal
government as we've been providing
testing supplies and accessing resources
he told me that they actually cleared
30,000 tests a day in New Jersey and
most importantly in that state where at
one point nearly 40% of those tested and
tested positive for the coronavirus and
now the governor of New Jersey informed
us that they're less than 5% but they're
hardly alone mr. president 42 states are
now testing at less than 10% positive
rate and 20 states are testing at less
than 5% a positive rate the reality is
that now all 50 states
with the support that we've been
providing sending swabs and test tubes
and medium on a weekly basis at your
direction now all 50 states have tested
more than 2 percent of their population
giving us a much greater capacity to
identify outbreaks as they occur and
protect our citizens and the progress in
evidence is clear all across America we
see hospitalizations continuing to
decline new hospitalizations have
declined steadily and the chart that you
see before you from April until today
and most importantly while the president
often says that one loss is too many we
do we welcome word that fatalities are
declining precipitously all across the
country in fact yesterday in America
there were just 505 Americans who
succumbed to the corona virus and that
number had not we hadn't seen that
number in daily losses since March the
reality is because of the cooperation
and the compassion of the American
people
we're getting there we're getting there
America
and mr. president at your direction
we're gonna continue to work closely
with states around the country to expand
testing and resources we're going to
continue to make sure personal
protective equipment flows but finally
what we're going to continue to do is
focus on the most vulnerable even as we
begin to see evidence that we are
starting to put this coronavirus
epidemic in the past all the more we are
going to continue to to surge the
resources and surge the kind of testing
and partnership with states and health
care providers to ensure that our
seniors and anyone with an underlying
immune deficiency anyone that's
vulnerable to the corona virus is
immediately identified and and protected
by every measure that's possible so mr.
president I thank you for the
opportunity we heard great enthusiasm
from governor's all across the country
in both political parties today we're
making great progress and I truly do
believe that with the continued
partnership that we have forged with
state and local governments with the
tremendous efforts of our health care
workers around America and with God's
help we will reopen America we will
continue to reopen our country safely
and protect our most vulnerable as we do
so Thank You mr. president you Mike very
much and I think I'll just add on to
what Mike said if we didn't act quickly
and smartly we would have had in my
opinion and in the opinion of others
anywhere from 10 to 20 and maybe even 25
times the number of deaths we closed the
border to China meaning we put on the
banned people coming in from China that
was a very big moment as dr. Fauci said
we saved thousands and thousands of
lives while we did that and that's true
but I think we would have had anywhere
from 10 to 20 or 25 times the number of
deaths if we didn't act the way we did
and also if we didn't act swiftly so if
we're very proud of our team and our
task force and Mike great job
Seema please
I want to start with thanking the one
person that's responsible for today's
announcement and that's president Trump
he's been steadfast in his commitment to
lowering the cost of drugs and
protecting the Medicare program and
making sure it works best for seniors
the president also knows that it's the
free market that leverages competition
and negotiation that that is what can
lower cost and improve quality for the
American patient and because of that
we've been working to slash Medicare's
anti-competitive regulations and it's
worked in the Medicare Part D program as
the president said we are seeing low
premiums a seven year low and in the
Medicare Advantage program we're seeing
a 13 year low in premiums so we're
putting money back in the pockets of
seniors and that means three billion
dollars in savings for patients and six
billion dollars in savings for taxpayers
in an absence of a congressional
solution we applied those same
principles to lowering the cost of
insulin we are waiving Obama care laws
that disincentivize plans from lowering
cost sharing for Medicare beneficiaries
and this is important because we know
that beneficiaries struggle to pay their
insulin costs its patients like Cindy
from Rochester New York she told us that
the high cost of insulin has impacted
her health and that she's been forced to
ration her insulin she said I know that
it's not good at all for my health and
I'm sure that I've affected some organs
negatively because of that lack of money
to purchase insulin but no longer thanks
to the president's leadership Medicare
seniors will pay no more than $35 for
their insulin and that's per month and
that's for all forms of insulin through
all phases of the Medicare Part D
program I also will say that some plans
are free to even go below the $35
and so they could even see lower
premiums as well I'm also proud to say
that we have over 88 health plans that
are participating in this model and that
represents over 1,750 plans that will
offer this low-cost insulin these plans
will be available during this year's
open enrollment which starts in October
and I want to thank the manufacturers
and the health plans for stepping up to
the plate for coming together to
negotiate this great senior savings
model it's going to make such a
difference to the lives of many seniors
across the country and I am optimistic
that this could be a model to lower the
costs of many other drugs in the
Medicare program and thank you again
President Trump for bringing lower-cost
priced insulin our seniors are going to
be saving an average of 66% in their
insulin cost and this is nothing short
of a godsend and with that I think we're
going to hear for one of our Medicare
beneficiaries thank you thank you I'm 68
years old and I rely on Medicare Part D
I've been a diabetic for over ten years
and during that time I've watched
insulin prices rise dramatically I pay
$400 a month now for insulin I
appreciate President Trump putting a
policy in place that will help people
like myself for the future as far as
insulin products thank you that's very
nice and many many people feel the same
way they can't actually believe it $35
and less and less and they were being
ripped off at a level that nobody's seen
before but that's true with a lot of
other things and we're taking care of
them too so I want to thank everybody
for being here in particular of these
great executives thank you very much
thank you very much you were very
impressive in your speech by the way
thank you very much John plays mr.
president can you tell us what you plan
to do regarding sanctions against China
for its pen
actions against Hong Kong and do you
also intend to put restrictions on F and
J visas for students and researchers
coming into the United States from China
your questions early we're doing it now
we're doing something now I think you'll
find it very interesting but I won't be
talking about it today I'll be talking
about it over the next couple of days
Chen okay but it's a very important
question yes please anybody yeah please
mr. president two questions about a
couple of things you've tweeted about in
the last few days were you meaning to
criticize Vice President Biden for
wearing a mask yesterday and can you
explain why you've been tweeting about a
conspiracy theory that has been proven
to not be true no Biden can wear a mask
but he was standing outside with his
wife perfect conditions perfect weather
they were inside they don't wear masks
and so I thought it was very unusual
that he had one on but I thought that
was fine I wasn't criticizing him at all
why would I ever do a thing like that
and your second question was I couldn't
hear you the second can you take it up
because I cannot hear I'll just speak
louder sir okay good you want to be
politically correct go ahead no sir I
just want to wear that the second
question was about your tweets about the
woman who died who you're suggesting
that Joe Scarborough was responsible
yeah a lot of people suggest that and
hopefully some day people are gonna find
out certainly a very suspicious
situation very sad very sad and very
suspicious question please ask you not
to Twitter have you seen the letter that
was written by her husband begging
Twitter to delete your tweets talking
about how hard it's been for his family
for him but I'm sure that ultimately
they want to get to the bottom of it and
it's a very serious situation I also saw
a clip with with Joe and Imus where they
were having a lot of fun at her expense
and I thought it was totally
inappropriate now it's a very suspicious
thing and I hope somebody gets to the
bottom of it it'll be a very good thing
as you know there's no statute of
limitations so it would be a very good
very good thing to do okay who's next
any questions on insulin yeah please
mr. president there's a bill in Congress
that would that's related to the weekers
it passed the Senate it's gonna be up in
the house are you are you willing to
sign that would take you to look at it
very strongly they're gonna report this
afternoon I'll be looking at it this
afternoon nothing special that you
mentioned on China
does that include sanctions it's
something you're gonna be hearing about
over the next before the end of the week
very powerfully I think yeah please yeah
is there any reason why someone who does
not have diabetes would take insulin is
there any sort of medical reason for
that I could ask that question to
anybody like to discuss that do you want
to discuss it please go ahead do you
know the answer either one of you or
both come on let's get these highly paid
executives up here to give the answer
Seema
please Jerome we picked a good one we
got it right well thank you mr. Prady I
think it's important for everyone to
know that as Tracy Brown highlighted
earlier one in three Americans is
actually either diabetic or pre-diabetic
and I would encourage folks to go to
diabetes org slash risk the risk - test
so diabetes org slash risk - test to
find out if you are at risk for diabetes
as far as insulin goes we know that
against 7 million people actually are
dependent on insulin we know that from a
type 1 diabetes standpoint 1.6 million
Americans have type 1 diabetes and most
all of them are dependent on insulin
your body mr. president actually makes
insulin endogenously and people such as
you and I we make our own insulin so yes
we do utilize insulin but we make it
ourselves other people who have diabetes
often times need exogenously made by
many of these great manufacturers here
so that they can be healthy and lived
long and successful lives and make no
mistake about it I think an get
affordable insulin they can live a long
and healthy life and that's what we're
here for today today is a very important
day it is a monumental day because Tracy
we've been working for years to try to
address the price of insulin for years
this is an important day and I want to
thank you mr. president I want to thank
all the people here from making that
insulin affordable to more people thank
you very much and Tracy do you agree
with it and the question I found to be a
very interesting one but is that an
unusual question or an unusual
circumstance
right okay good I thought it was a very
good question actually please good Thank
You mr. president we see in Europe
slowly from one country to the other
they are opening their borders and
letting people going from moving from
one country to the other
are you considering for the good of the
US economy are you considering lifting
the flight ban from Europe in the next
weeks well we're just putting a ban on
as you know going on immediately
essentially almost immediately to Brazil
and from Brazil into our country so from
Brazil to the United States to having a
very hard time in Brazil we'll be doing
certain announcements on other countries
including Europe as we move along and
where they're making progress we'll
start to open it up but only where
they're making progress they're making
some good progress I think we're making
very good progress we're making very
good progress on the economy the numbers
are better than anybody would have
anticipated and certainly I think that's
been reflected in the stock market which
had a very big day and it's over 25,000
and when you think 25,000 is a very high
number when you think that it was at
29,000 and now it's a 25 that's a very
big day it's up very substantially over
the last six months so we had a very big
day but people are seeing what's
happening they're seeing there is a
pent-up demand as I was predicting and
you're gonna see it more and more we
call it the transition to greatness and
it really is we're gonna have a third
quarter that's going to be good we're
gonna have a fourth quarter that has the
potential to be really good and we're
gonna have the best year one of the best
years we've ever had next year that's
what we see yeah John go ahead mr.
president is it your intention to bring
American forces home from Afghanistan by
Thanksgiving Day and is the Pentagon
drawing up plans to that effect well I
think everyone knows we're down to less
than 8,000 troops
we're with leadership in many different
fields and in many different parts of of
that country we're with we're dealing
with the Taliban we're dealing with the
president the president now has gotten
themselves straightened out with the two
present
but we're dealing with because they had
as you know they had competing factors
and factions yeah I think we want to get
within 19 years we're really not acting
as soldiers were acting as police and
we're not sent over there to be
policemen but were there 19 years and
yeah I think that's enough and they
understand we're having very positive
talks we want to bring our soldiers back
home we want to bring them back home and
we're not only talking about there we're
talking about other countries also we
bring our soldiers back home we can
always go back if we have to we have to
go back we'll go back and we'll go back
raging and then we'll go back as
warriors fighters but right now we're
policing and we're not meant to be a
police force we're meant to be a
fighting force it's Thanksgiving Day the
target no I have no target but as soon
as reasonable over a period of time but
as soon as racism we're down to 7,000
some odd soldiers right now and in Iraq
we're down to 4000 soldiers so we're
making a lot of progress in Syria you
remember John on the border when I took
the soldiers out of the border everyone
said oh that's so terrible well I spoke
to President Erdogan yesterday of Turkey
the borders been fined without us
they've been policing that border for
2,000 years all of a sudden we had
thousands of soldiers there doing their
work for what
guarding Syria and Turkey on a border a
very long border now we want our troops
back home we took them out that was a
year ago I was criticized nothing
happened except they're watching their
own borders now we kept the oil but at
some point we'll take care of the Kurds
with respect to the oil and get out yeah
please go ahead mr. president quickly on
your meeting with Governor Cuomo
tomorrow yeah he's coming in can you say
what you're getting to be discussing do
you have a particular agenda do you
think you'll discuss the Gateway project
that the Hudson River
I would imagine we would but he he asked
for the meeting so we'll see what he
wants but he has for the meeting
Governor Cuomo and will be coming in
sometime tomorrow
yeah please good what can you tell us
about the documents reportedly
Declassified by Rick Grinnell just
before Easter
down as dni are you prepared to release
the transcripts of the flinches lyac
conversations yeah I'd like to hear it
too I mean I'd like to hear the FBI as
you know said that he didn't lie
and certainly the conversation almost
regardless it was a good conversation he
was allowed to do it and the Muller
people who are have been proven yeah
we're very bad very bad things they did
very bad thing a lot of bad things are
being found out about the hoax greatest
hoax in the history of our country and
it was an illegal hoax and a very
dangerous hoax and a lot of bad things
have been found out about Muller and the
gang so I would like to hear that
conversation yeah I would like to hear
it personally so whatever they want me
to do I'll do I think Rick Grinnell has
done an incredible job and things are
happening now that I always do this was
the answer this was a a an attempted
coup by a bunch of dirty cops and others
these are dirty cops dishonest slime
bags all right yeah question go ahead
Jeff thank you sir mr. president on
Friday you announced that you wanted
governor's to reopen churches and
synagogues and mosques and you said you
would overrule them if they if they
declined to do so can you explain what
authority you had in mind when you said
that you would do that I can absolutely
do it if I want to and I don't think I'm
gonna have to because it's starting to
open up we need our churches and our
synagogues and our mosques we want them
open churches synagogues mosques and
other we want them open and we want them
open as soon as possible now I can tell
you I know a lot of pastors a lot of
rabbis Imams and they want to take care
of their people they want to take care
they don't want anyone getting hurt or
sick and they're going to take care of
their people we need we need these
people we need we need people that are
going to be leading us in faith that
we're opening them up and if I have to I
will override any governor that wants to
play games if they want to play games
that's okay but we will win and we have
many different ways where I can override
them and if I have to I'll do that
but we want our churches and our
synagogues and our mosques etc we want
them open now there may be some areas by
the way where the pastor or whoever may
feel that it's not quite ready and
that's okay that's okay but let that be
the choice of the congregation and the
pastor John go ahead mr. president how
long will you give North Carolina
Governor Roy Cooper to provide you with
the information that you and the RNC
are asking for before you decide to look
elsewhere for a venue for the RNC
convention in August well as you know we
don't have much time because we have to
know that if we're going to spend
millions of dollars on an arena we want
to be in North Carolina I love North
Carolina one North Carolina we just had
a big two races that we won recently for
Congress in North Carolina two very big
races that the press didn't want to
report on if we would have lost them it
would have been the biggest story in
political history but we just won two
races it's a very important place to me
I love North Carolina in fact my son
Erik and Laura named a baby Carolina and
came from I think both but she was born
in North Carolina as you know Laura so
it's a very important place to me but at
the same time and I think the people
understand this we have a governor that
doesn't want to open up the state and we
have a date of August in the end of
August and we have to know before we
spend millions and millions of dollars
on an arena to make it magnificent for
the convention and we have tremendous
people I mean economic development
consequences are tremendous for the
state we have to know that when the
people come down they're going to have
the doors open now if the governor can't
tell us very soon unfortunately we'll
have no choice this is nothing to do
with us this is between the governor and
North Carolina and the people of North
Carolina but the people want it and
we'll have to see whether or not the
governor he's a Democrat and a lot of
the Democrats for political reasons
don't want to open up their states so
we'll see if that works but I don't
think it will I'd love to have it in
North Carolina that was why I chose at
Charlotte but we're going to see
we're gonna see and at the end we need a
fast decision from the governor he's
going to have to because he's but he's
been acting very very slowly and very
suspiciously but we'll find out a
question place what's terms of soon are
we talking a week Toby yeah I mean we
can't take we're talking about a very
short period of time
it's a massive expenditure and we have
to know yeah I would say within a week
that certainly we have to know now if he
can't do it if he feels that he's not
going to do it all he has to do is tell
us and then we'll have to pick another
location and I will tell you a lot of
locations want it but I picked North
Carolina because I do love that state
and it would have been a perfect place
for it and it still would be but he's
got to say that you know when thousands
of people come to the arena that they'll
be able to get in does that make sense I
mean you know we'll spend millions and
millions of dollars on this magnificent
design but in the end they have to be
able to get in I don't want to have it
where we get there and then they
announce after all the money was spent
all the work was done all the people
travel in guess what you can't put
anybody in the arena or you can put a
tiny number of people in the arena we
can't do that John yeah please go ahead
there are now more than still more than
a dozen states in this country where
case numbers are rising so why is it
suspicious if a governor says look we
don't want to move that that quickly we
still think we need to shut down oh I
think it's fine I have to do it look at
the governor's in certain ways have to
do what they want to do but they have to
tell me what they're doing and when it
comes to churches etc they will be
overridden by me when it comes to other
things and you know many other things
they won't if I think some things being
done incorrectly or wrong I'm going to
do it but you have different governors
and they have very different views on
where they are and where they're going
so we'll see what happens please go
ahead I'm sorry I'm sure you saw the
images from over the weekend of people
out on Memorial Day weekend they were
crowding pools crowding boardwalks do
you have any message for those people
yeah always be safe you want to be safe
we're opening up but you want to be safe
go ahead please thank you about mail-in
voting you've been you've been speaking
out against a lot against out of Long
Island voting yeah you'll be speaking a
lot of
about that what why should somebody who
is afraid of getting coronavirus going
to public places standing in a line etc
why should they no why should they not
be allowed to to mail in well that's
gonna be in a long time from now number
one you know it's quite a ways away
number one but when you do were all
mail-in voting ballots you're asking for
fraud people steal them out of mail
boxes people print them and then they
sign them and they give them in that the
people don't even know where they're
double-counted people take them away
they force people to vote they harvest
you know what harvesting is they take
many many ballots and they put them all
together and then they just dump them
and nobody has any idea whether they're
crooked or not look you do mail-in
voting now it's another thing to do
absentee voting or if somebody has a
medical condition where they go through
a process and they get an absentee
ballot that's okay that's different but
in California the governor sent I hear
Ora sending millions of ballots all over
the state millions to anybody to anybody
people that aren't citizens illegals
anybody that walks in California is
going to get a ballot we're not going to
destroy this country by allowing things
like that to happen we're not destroying
our country this has more to do with
fairness and honesty and really our
country itself because when that starts
happening you don't have a fair if you
have a rigged system you have a rigged
system and that's what would happen
so mail-in ballots and the governor of
California did better than any that I
could ever do in terms of explaining
when he sent out or will send out and I
don't know I think it's maybe partially
already done millions and millions of
ballots to anybody in California that's
walking or breathing many of those
people don't have the right to vote well
they'll be voting and you know what
we're not going to let it happen because
you're subvert our process and you're
making our country a joke and the
Democrats are doing it because in theory
it's good for them although last week we
won two big races we won
Wisconsin and one in California
California 25 we won a tremendous race
in California that was I was interested
because at the end of the race they
brought in the Democrats Democrat
governor same governor he brought in
voting booths not mail-in voting booths
because they were losing they saw that
through the ballots but no you can't do
that you can't do the mail-in ballots
because you can have tremendous fraud
and remember what I said they'll be
grabbing them from mailboxes they'll
even be printing them they'll use the
same paper the same machines and they'll
be printing ballots illegally and
they'll be sending them in by the
hundreds of thousands and nobody's going
to know the difference we can't do that
you want to vote you really have to
absentee is okay you're sick your way as
an example I have to do an absentee
because I'm voting in Florida and I
happen to be president I live in that
very beautiful house over there that's
painted white so that's okay and it's
okay for people that are sick and they
can't get up something you know
something but voting is a great honor
it's a great honor and people love to go
out and vote and I want to keep it that
way and if we don't keep it that way
we'll have nothing but a rigged system
in this country we can't do that thank
you very much everybody thank you
[Music]